so reading that paper i got really
excited really inspired
so i've set a third year project third
year undergraduate project and their job
is to analyze drum patterns but to do it
over a wider range of drum patterns that
are described in this paper and in
particular to take a different drummer
and a different pattern similar in many
ways but um much as i like picaro as a
drummer
i must admit that michael mcdonald song
doesn't quite do it for me
so we're going to choose a drummer
another drummer who's recognized as
possibly arguably the best rock drummer
in the world he's topped poles so many
times in so many drummond magazines and
won so many awards and that's neil peart
from rush there's a song called a rush a
very famous rush song called tom sawyer
where it's the same type of 16th note
pattern so
but with one hand he also plays it with
one hand so there are very many
similarities with the cargo pieces
the
the groove is different and how he
chooses to accent um stuff is is
different but the same overall idea so
at this point you do not know how much i
would like to be able to turn around and
say in this corner we've got neil peart
from rush
we've got sean riley sean riley is going
to play the
opening few bars of tom sawyer to give
you an idea of that drum partner to give
you an idea that groove
um yeah absolutely interesting
so what do we want from you well if you
think you can do a better job than sean
or indeed if you think you can do a
better job than neil peart or even if
you don't think you can do a better job
but you're a drummer and you'd like to
help out science and indeed you'd like
to get your name in a paper
then what we want you to do is to send
in examples samples of you drumming the
start of of tom sawyer or indeed the
whole thing it's up to you the first
eight 16 bars will be fine what we're
interested in is those fluctuations
we're interested from drummer to drummer
let's look at this and see how universal
this effect is and we want you to send
in samples in terms of wav files mp3s
midi files whatever you like to the
email address it'll be down here
somewhere brady will put it down there
at some point and also there'll be lots
more information available via blog
brady will have linked it down there as
well so i must admit
okay as some of you will remember or
might know i'm a major rush fan
sort of it's sort of i must admit
coincidental because
pearch is what is recognized as one of
the best drummers and the pattern fits
in and the whole analysis will work but
it doesn't harm that it's a rushed song
i must admit and also
what a motivation for this video is that
for my birthday my wife and kids got me
aerodrums if you haven't come across
aerodrums yet go and google it now
because they are they are just fantastic
they were developed by a couple of um
phd students at trinity college dublin
and if you've got aerodrums please send
in samples because the one of the great
things is that instead of having a real
physical surface with aerodrums you're
basically flailing into air and we're
very interested in what difference that
makes in the response times what
difference it makes in the fluctuations
how much of it is due to your muscle
response and your motor system response
and how much of it is due to the bounce
back from the hi-hat and the drums so
i'm going to try and play tom sawyer
um this should be good for a laugh let's
go so you put these reflectors on your
feet
let's turn it up
just let me
sort myself out for a second because the
drumsticks moved okay so i'm well off
so
ah
oh damn age
me right
you